bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france aujourd'hui le
parquet au liban a donc interrogé des
ministres des anciens ministres dont
ghazi aridi et l'ex ministre des
transports il s'agit de savoir de faire
un peu la lumière sur ce qui s'est passé
après la double explosion consécutive
aux stocks justement de 2007 150 tonnes
de nitrate d'ammonium
que faut-il attendre de ces auditions
effectivement quand il ya un clim
il faut qu'il y ait des des malfaiteurs
il faut qu'il y ait des criminels il
faut qu'ils aient des responsables c'est
pour celà justice libanaise actuellement
et en présence d'enquêteurs
internationaux à leur tête des français
qui ont été envoyées par les autorités
françaises compétentes et le problème
c'est de qualifier les crimes en premier
dans tous ses éléments techniques même
peut-être chimiques bactériologiques on
sépare et puis qui a fait ça qu il
expliqué qui sont les responsables qui
sont tenus responsable criminellement
délit tuellement administrativement et
sûrement politiquement ce qui s'est
passé n'est pas quelque chose de 2,2 de
passagers c'est quelque chose de très
dangereux il faut qu'il y ait des
jugements transparent et des
investigations qui font confiance au
peuple libanais en premier à la
communauté internationale en 2d sinon
l'interférence internationale va avoir
du
de plus de plus en plus avec les
enquêteurs et peut-être avec une
commission d'investigation de la part
des nations unies actuellement on attend
le la cour de justice qui va commencer à
aborder le toutes les enquêtes et
investigations
les auditions et tout suite à la
décision du conseil des ministres du
gouvernement saxo le temps de transférer
le tout le dossier de ce clip à la cour
de justice qui est un tribunal spécial
d'exception afin de juger les
malfaiteurs et les criminels alors il ya
des experts donc quand vous l'avez
signalé des experts mandatés par l'onu
qui réclame une enquête indépendante
rapide sur l'explosion par crainte
justement d'une impunité que certains
responsables politiques libanais restent
justement dans l'impunité et le
président michel aoun et refuse une
enquête internationale
pour quelles raisons effectivement suite
à la décision du gouvernement sortant de
tancer les dossiers auprès de la cour de
justice
le gouvernement libanais ne peut plus
demander du moins actuellement la
différence et l'intervention des nations
unies pour procéder à une résolution
internationale de la part du conseil
d'éviter dé sécurité pour former une
commission d enquête internationale mais
ça veut pas dire que les enquêtes à
l'international les ex
internationaux ne sont pas là les
enquêteurs internationaux sont là les
les experts de toutes parts ils ont
commencé par les français ça commence à
peler français actuellement hier on a on
a entendu que les américains sont là le
mirail alors pour donner une crédibilité
aux investigations il faut qu'il y ait
une observation l'observation du peuple
libanais car il ya une certaine scission
entre le peuple libanais et les
gouvernants suite à tout ce qui s'est
passé de corruption colonisation vol du
deet est aidée de l'argent public et
privé à la banque et ou aux banques et
tout est actuellement avec ce crime
contre l'humanité que qu'on qualifie
très bien là il ya des milliers de gens
qui ont perdu leur des centaines de
militants ont perdu leurs foyers
il ya des gens qui ont perdu leur vie
leurs familles et tous alors c'est pas
quelque chose de passagers on n'accepte
pas au liban ni en tant que personne
humaine ni en tant que juriste ni en
tant que défendeurs de l'est de droits
de la personne que c'est ce qui s'est
passé parce sans punition
alors si les politiciens au liban ne
sont pas responsables ça veut pas dire
que la justice n'est pas là la justice
libanaise
si elle ne se leurre pas transvaal en fm
et sans faille si vous voulez en guinée
et sans protections politiques comme
c'était le cas dans plusieurs calibres
dans le passé alors c'est la communauté
internationale qui venait de judo qui va
qui veulent prendre la relève mais
actuel avec les gentils ce qui est la
cour de justice donc qu'il était en
charge de cette antenne de cette
procédure
justement est ce qu'elle est
transparente et fiable
oui la cour de justice en fait c'est le
ce sont les juges de la cour de
cassation et le procureur général de la
lecture
x et le procureur général et de cette
poule alors en principe c'est oui c'est
inspirant ce sont des juges qui sont
très qualifiés et compétents et qu'ils
ont la confiance du peuple
mais le problème n'est pas là le
problème se situe au niveau des
interférences politiques afin de
protéger des responsables politiques
administratifs des peut-être judiciaires
et militaires sécurité qui ont quelques
y sont tenus par une certaine
responsabilité criminelle des
délictuelle pour être ministre at il est
sûrement politique alors c'est ça ce
sont des et lg lancé le 7 août toute la
problématique se situe au niveau de
l'indépendance de la justice au liban
pour juger les criminels de ce qui est
dans ce crime contre l'humanité et pour
les criminels qui ont qui ont mené le
pays où désarroi financier économique et
politique dé toute une dernière question
c'est vrai qu'il ya une colère des
libanais qui on l'a vu on manifeste dans
la rue toujours contre la classe
dirigeante qu'elle juge corrompu le
parlement libanais a entériné l'état
d'urgence décrété à beyrouth
il ya des inquiétudes par rapport à cela
pour les libanais qui manifestent
effectivement donc l'état d'urgence est
limité à la ville de beyrouth à la
capitale c'est à dire qu'aucun qu'on
dénomme beyrouth ministre et il n'y a
pas de problème vu que les décisions de
du de l'armée libanaise ne peuvent pas
atteindre les libertés publiques et on a
bien vu dans sa halle et la liberté au
liban c'est quelque chose de sacré
personne ne peut empiéter sur les droits
des gens de protester contre les
gouvernants contre la corruption contre
tout ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à ce crime
crapuleux
alors la liberté
va continuer un nouveau gouvernement de
technocrates indépendants va revoir lieu
même même s'il ya des signes de
dissension même s'il ya des troubles ici
et là même s'il ya des pressions mais en
fin de compte avec la la le support de
la communauté internationale de la
france en particulier des états unis des
arabes de tous les pays amis au liban
qui aiment le liban qui aiment que le
liban soit en état de stabilité avec la
ténacité ténacité la persévérance des
jeunes libanais le liban va pouvoir
commencer un processus d'ajustement mais
cette pénible on a peur que la violence
ne soit pas là encore une frappe mais en
fin de compte la liberté la démocratie
et un état transparent à des coûts on
espère que les coûts ne soit pas et donc
merci à vous en transferts avocat paris
avérous docteur en droit international